[Applause]
all right so they gave him me extra cuz
we love Charles yeah I didn't know this
about you but you start and I feel like
I've known you for a bit but like you
started on Broadway I I started on
Broadway I didn't finish it I know but I
didn't know that well yeah I mean I love
that you New York suits you really well
I can tell that Kell it comes right
through the screen and um it suited me
for a quick minute I was in Los Angeles
and auditioned for the show so called
Smokey Joe's Cafe it was a review of the
songs of Liber and sters so great I
pered that pop Choir in high school you
did well that years before that I
auditioned for the Broadway show and I
just had a really great audition for
years before that I would get a vocal
audition for a Broadway show and they go
all right they want to see a call back
and I go uh For What and they say oh
they it's a dance audition I go well I
don't dance so I probably shouldn't go
do that yeah just show up and lie and
say you can no that's what they said
they just want to see if you can move
and apparently I can't move but anyway
this one audition I just was free and
loose I did a couple Elvis songs hound
dog Libra and stro wrote hound dog and
Jail House Rock yeah and so I think I
Bamboozled them and then I went here on
Broadway and we were rehearsing in the
studios downtown and I looked around and
I was surrounded by people that were
just legit Broadway Talent my leading
lady was dele Lively and she was
unbelievable such a great dancer singer
and then I think it was about 3 weeks in
the director finally showed up to see
where we were and I could just on his
face with him watching me you know that
thing you have an impostor syndrome and
you're like I don't belong here and
everybody's going to figure that out I
all day well they figured it out he
looked at me and he said in front of
everybody he stopped the whole thing he
goes CH let me ask you a question do you
dance and I said well Jerry that falls
under things you should have asked at
the
audition and uh and I said I'm doing my
best I will get it by Showtime I promise
you that that uh about a week later he
gave me a very nice phone call and he
said we really appreciate your hard work
but we're going to have to so they
recast the role and uh what the first
thing I found out was that I had a
contract so I got paid for a year for
not being in that show that's like the
one time you're thankful for contracts
it was unbelievable I'm at six months in
I go to my mailbox I'm like honey I got
a raise I got a bump at six months so
and another thing I found out is if I
had done that show I would not have been
available to get on Whose Line Is It
Anyway which changed my life being on
that show for a number of years and then
a final couple two things um years later
six or eight years later we're walking
some fair in in LA and we see Del
Lively and her husband who was the guy
they replaced me with oh all these
things had to happen they had three kids
he had one in her arm one in the
stroller one walking and they were
amazing and we talked and it was really
and I go I think it's very important
that you guys understand and know and
remember that you have all this piss you
have this parad
because Charles eston can't
dance you're
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome thank you guys y'all have a
great night I'm going
home